die youtube trends in der zeit voll mit
scheiße
wow 360 die schutzhülle führen und neun
euro 90 instagram follower bekommen
kostenlos instagram followers einfache
reinigung des thermomix mit diesen hack
schnell gemacht einfach thermomix folge
des 2806 endlich wieder vereint bei
sturm der liebe siebtes baby
ich habe die trends jetzt über tagen
beziehungsweise wochen beobachtet und
habe dabei festgestellt dass immer
häufiger auch witze in den trend sind
hier versteht mich da wirklich nicht
falsch dann wird einfach nur ein witz
eingeblendet das video geht der minute
ich meine hier witz blondine
norddeutschen rollenden zug und es gibt
eine minute drei deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht hey ich lese heute witze vor
sonst sagt einheit
nachdem er einen surfer gefressen hat
net serviert somit frühstücksbrettchen
was geht eine schwangere frauen eine
bäckerei und sagt ich krieg ein brot
darauf der bäcker sachen gibt's weil es
auch nicht lustig da sagt die johanna
zum papa ich wünsche mir als geschenk
ein pony zu weihnachten dann wurde der
papa okay wir in ordnung beantwortet die
ohren hat wirklich ich liebe dich über
alles und dann papa am heiligabend so
johanna dieser termin steht garantiert
eine dicke frau in eine bäckerei und
sagt ich möchte ihnen rumkugeln darauf
der bäcker aber nicht in meinem laden
wiederum kugeln weil sie so erwarte mal
auf mich schatz ich mache nur noch
schnell mein make up du brauchst auch
kein make up und das ist aber lieb von
dir ich mag wenn du mir speicher ist du
brauchst plastische chirurgie das ist
einfach nur gemein sagt eine frau
doch da herr doktor ich komme mir so
unglaublich über für sich vor da aber
der doktor hat der nächste bitte wissen
ist ein scheiß arzt doktor doktor ich
habe jeden morgen um sieben uhr
stuhlgang
das ist doch super mensch es ist auch
sehr gut aber ich stehe es um halb acht
auf ok der ging klar ich hatte einen
traum dass ich ein riesiges brötchen
aufgegessen habe als ich aufwachte war
mein kissen weg das ist das ist
überhaupt nicht lustig dass erhält man
wenn man einen rottweiler und einen
jaguar kreuzt ärger mit dem postboten
was zwei elefanten sehen so zum ersten
mal einen nackten mann da sagt der eine
idee wir finden können nicht reden also
ist er ich kann es nicht fassen da hat
wirklich der nachbar heute nacht um 3
uhr bei uns geklingelt also mir wer vor
schreck fast die bohrmaschine ausland
gefallen sagten man herr doktor ich
kriege meine vororten ich bin kann ich
nicht bringen sonst ist das wieder ab 18
da sagt die oma du brummbären rate mal
wer kein unterhöschen und kein bh trägt
der sagt dir ob ach deshalb ist heute
dein gesicht so straff die berühmten
letzten worte eines fallschirmspringers
immer diese scheiss motten das traurig
weil er ist jetzt tot sagt man zu seiner
frau schatz ist die hose nicht ein
bisschen zu eng für dich eine andere die
frau ist schon lustig so formuliert dass
du sterben willst weil er zu ihr mal so
dass sie angeblich fans haben frauen und
handgranaten gemeinsam siehst du den
ring ab ist ein haus weg
aber warum hast du eigentlich sieht man
mal geheiratet
siehst du den gerät die kinder können es
auch nicht verstehen er okay da ging
morgens in der bäckerei sagt der mann
zur kassiererin ich hätte gerne das ding
da bitte da sagt die bedienung zucker
schnecke und dann sagt er okay zucker
schnecke das ding da bitte weil er sie
dann dachte dass sie eher sie zucker
schnecke nennen soll weil obwohl sie
eigentlich heute war ich echt richtig
sauer auf mein navi ich hab's dann
angeschrieben es soll zur hölle fahren
und naja 25 minuten später stand ich
dann vor dem haus meiner schwiegermutter
kurze wenn ich leute umarmen das gibt
ihnen das gefühl stark zu sein
den kannte ich frage an siri wieso bin
ich eigentlich unsere angst engere siri
öffnet die frontkamera
das ist mir schon mal passiert junge
geht kaputt da wird auch er sagt aber
auch den schultern
okay dass das ist dann ekelhaft sagten
beamte zum anderen ich weiß gar nicht
was die leute gegen uns haben wir tun
doch nichts als die wahrheit wenn diese
lässt sich präzise an die wand gemalt ja
der spiegel sagt der vater zum sohn wie
du hast nur sechs in deutsch habt doch
geübt mit du wer schreibt diese scheiß
auf diese website
freundlich ganz wirklich nicht verstehen
warum die trends in letzter zeit voll
sind mit irgendwelchen gesponserten
komischen videos wie man instagram
vorderer bekommt oder wie man in welche
produkte rein nicht oder mit
irgendwelchen wilson oder irgendwie so
max hatte letztens die theorie dass das
aus irgend so einer komischen apple app
store ist irgend so ein spiel und dann
muss man um neue ingame währung bekommen
sich eine werbung anschauen auf youtube
und dadurch erkennt der youtube
algorithmus dass die videos krasser als
andere videos obwohl das quasi nur
gekauft ist durch diese spiele app aber
keine ahnung ob das wirklich stimmt ist
auf jeden fall eine logische
schlussfolgerung sonst kann ich nicht
erklären warum solche komischen videos
den trend sind vielleicht hat euch mein
video heute gefallen
ich hoffe ihr habt genauso wenig gelacht
wie ich wollte nur mal auf der website
gehen ein paar witze vorlesen bevor
diese witze immer jetzt einzelne
irgendwelchen zwei sekunden videos auf
youtube hochgeladen werden selbst
natürlich das sieht jetzt allerdings
auch verändern sich vielleicht trotzdem
gefahren habe will ich mich selber einen
daumen hoch freuen und jetzt kommt das
aus roth das was ihr vom video das war
es jetzt hier vom video hier können
jetzt jemanden kanal abonnieren oder
hier unten meinen job ausschenken jetzt
findet ihr zwei andere videos und wenn
ihr schon abonnenten zeit könnt ihr auf
die glocke klicken dann willkommen die
winde nach richtungen
[Musik]